even for a country long gripped by
violence it was a shocking crime on the
morning of November 23 2009 a convoy of
vehicles carrying journalists and
members of a political family were on
their way to an electoral event in
Maguindanao province in the southern
Philippines they never reached their
destination a gang of armed men stopped
and forced them to a hilltop in the
village of Messala there they were
repeatedly shot 58 people were killed
over a period of hours and buried in a
mass grave 32 or journalists others were
members of the Maldonado family
political rivals to the powerful
impeccable plan two key witnesses
interviewed exclusively by Al Jazeera
said the armed men were working for the
late governor and Ilan Padawan and sons
and that they witnessed how the family
planned and executed the victims
since then two governments have come and
gone and there have been no convictions
the man with the data family decided to
take their case to the courts but the
case has been difficult from the
beginning more than 200 people are
accused more than a hundred are in jail
and at least 80 at large
now Supreme Court officials see verdicts
are expected this month this memorial
was built on the same hills where the
victims were murdered the Maguindanao
massacre was one of the country's worst
cases of political violence and the
single deadliest attack against
journalists in global history the
families of those who died say fighting
for justice has been difficult and
painful we expect nothing more than a
full conviction for the most barbaric
inhuman act they have committed we
waited for long and suffered so much the
families say for years they've felt
abandoned by the government and the
public they say has become apathetic in
the case but they remain determined
fighting not just for justice but to be
remembered and ensure their country will
not forget the brutality of what
happened 10 years ago in the village of
Messala Jamela Alan Logan al-jazeera
Maguindanao province southern
Philippines